my name is timothy snyder and i am here
to welcome you to the first
in a series of lectures which are
organized within the framework of a
frankie seminar here at yale university
the seminar is is run by presser jason
stanley and myself its title is mass
incarceration in the soviet union and
the united states we we teach this as a
regular yale class but we have the
privilege and the pleasure of being able
to invite people from whom we've learned
and people whom we admire and people
whose work we're reading in the class
to give public lectures as well so i'll
be introducing and the students of the
class are present as as well as others
of you who have who have joined and and
thank you for that i'm going to briefly
introduce ann applebaum
she is known
uh
on the one side as an author of a series
of extremely important um and lauded
books on the history of communism
there is a
most recently there's there's a history
of the famine in ukraine um red famine
which which has brought the academic
debate um and her own interpretation
into into a highly accessible form um i
learned a lot from that book
a few years ago there was a book about
the post-war takeovers actually a
slightly revisionist account of the
post-war communist takeovers in eastern
europe under the title iron curtain and
then um towards the beginning of this
century in 2003 to 2004
ann wrote the book
for which she won a big prize uh and and
which we are reading in the class and
which will be part of her subject today
it's the it's called gulag a history um
the clearly the most accessible account
of the gulag um as as as well as
providing not just documentation but
themes and interpretation
and is is however also the author of a
book which which um which in some sense
stays with me the most it's called
between east and west and those of you
who are students and thinking about how
you're going to spend the rest of your
life the book is a kind of meditation
among many other things on on that but
in that book um there is this kind of
foresight the book is is is is a couple
of decades old now more a kind of a kind
of advance warning that there are things
between poland and russia that there are
these countries this yellow roofs this
ukraine and that someday they're going
to matter um and there are a number of
other things in the book there's a
there's a there's an interesting
reference to to anti-semitism and and
the future of the jewish question in
eastern europe so
anne has written an awful lot and from a
number of different angles um at a time
when we're more and more specialized and
as has has done two things which are
unusual in in writing about the
communist world she's also been a
prominent a prominent journalist about
europe and the united states catching
many of the most important stories for
example of the trump administration
right at the beginning and finally she
functions not just in the united states
and not just in europe well that's
already a lot but from many different
international angles and in this way she
in these ways she is something which is
rare these days all too rare which is an
intellectual we're very glad to have ann
introduce these lectures and and and
help get our course make a start again
the subject for lecture is the gulag
what we now know and why it matters and
the floor is yours
tim thank you so much um i um
so enjoy these these long introductions
um
you know you you you also
you you play so many different roles as
well um
uh as does jason and i'm really i've had
a chance to look at the syllabus for
your course and it's a very
interesting one i i'm
sorry i'm not taking it myself you're
really combining a lot of different
things um this evening i'm going to talk
a lot about something that for americans
in this context maybe
may sound a little bit different or
strange and it's
not not merely the history of the gulag
but the legacy and memory of the gulag
how does it continue to matter or not
matter in russian politics today and
actually as i was thinking about
speaking this evening i realized that
i'm talking to a generation that might
not know
that the gulag for
many decades was a scarcely known hardly
understood subject it was a it was a
vast system of camps tucked far away in
the soviet union um most americans most
europeans knew very little about it we
had well i'll speak about that a little
bit more
um and it only very really came to light
in its full um you know and it's in in
we only really began to understand what
it was and exactly how big it was
um after soviet archives began to open
in the 1990s and i was extremely lucky
to be able to work in the soviet union
in the 1990s that's a that's a whole
other subject which if some of you want
to discuss afterwards i'm i'm happy to
talk about and my book was based on um
in some cases you know the first glance
and documents that nobody had seen or
nobody had seen
outside of russia for a long time um
and and it was really in the in the
process of doing that in the process of
going through
these documents that we began to
understand
um really what the gulag was um and so
although the legacy of stalin's crimes
and the and the gulag itself will be the
ultimate subject of my talk i will begin
with a brief account
of what it is that we know now so what
did we learn about the camps since the
breakup of the soviet union you know
what we know now that we didn't know 30
years ago
um obviously in writing my history of
the gulag i just i didn't claim to have
discovered a brand new topic that had
never been touched on before um some of
you will know that sultry nissan's
famous book the gulag archipelago which
was a a kind of an oral history and of
the camp system that he published in the
west as a piece of sami's dot meaning it
was not published ever in the soviet
union but it was published outside of
the ussr in the 1970s although that was
a document based on his own experiences
and on the experiences of other people
he didn't have archives
actually he got the outline of the story
uh largely right you know he didn't have
archives um but he did understand the
basic outlines of the gulag's history
from its earliest incarnation on the
solevsky islands and the white sea um
and how it spread across the far north
from there and then across the country
um but as a kind of um as a kind of
asterisk you know in the years that i
spent researching my book i concluded
that archives really do make a
difference in how we understand soviet
history and so i was able to work in
archives in moscow and corellia
i had access to documents from archives
in saint petersburg perm vorkuta kolema
novosibirsk
at one point i was handed a part of the
archive of a small camp called kedrovy
shore in the far north and i was
politely asked if i wanted to buy it
which i did and it's now at the hoover
institute
what was available to me was often quite
ordinary it was the day-to-day archive
of the gulag administration for example
with inspectors reports and financial
accounts and letters from the camp
directors to moscow
but it's true that when reading these
kinds of documents the full extent of
the system
and its importance to the soviet economy
came sharply into focus
so for example
um these documents enabled me to be far
more precise than had ever been possible
in the past and so thanks to archives we
were able to learn that
there were at least
476 different camp systems in the soviet
era
um each one made up of hundreds or even
thousands of individual camps or lag
punks so the camps were there would be a
there would be a a central camp and then
there would be kind of um lug punks and
this was particularly true of the
forestry camp so there would be one camp
and then there would be small forestry
cramps all up and down a highway usually
and sometimes they were spread out over
thousands of square miles of otherwise
empty tundra
we also know now that the vast majority
of people in them prisoners were
peasants and workers and not the
intellectuals who later wrote the famous
memoirs and books there were some there
too but they were smaller numbers
and we also know that with a few
exceptions the camps were not
constructed explicitly in order to kill
people
stalin preferred to use firing squads to
conduct his mass executions he did kill
people on mass but not in camps
nevertheless at times they were very
lethal
so nearly a quarter of the gulags
prisoners died during the war years for
example between 1941 and 1945.
um they were also very fluid so
prisoners left because they died because
they escaped because they had short
sentences
because they were being released into
the red army or because they had been
promoted from prisoner to guard which
sometimes happened there were also
frequent amnesties for the old and for
the ill
for pregnant women and anyone else who
was no longer useful to the forced labor
system
but these releases were invariably
followed by new waves of arrests so it
was a it was a fluid system it wasn't
static um people's sentences could
change either be either be much
lengthened or much shortened even as
they were there um it wasn't a rule of
law based system it wasn't you know
people weren't sentenced by real courts
they didn't have real sentences i mean
sometimes they had these kind of
kangaroo courts and they were called
troikas
um but it was a the the camp population
actually changed uh according to
the soviet union's labor needs
but as a result of this between 1929
which is when they first became a mass
phenomenon and 1953 which is the year of
stalin's death some 18 million people
passed through them
in addition a further six or seven
million people were deported
not to camps but to exile villages
and so in total that means that the
number of people with some experience of
incarceration or imprisonment in
stalin's soviet union could have run as
high as 25 million which is about at
that time was about 15 percent of the
population
um we also know where these camps were
namely everywhere um and so although
some of you who know sultanates and who
know soviet literature might be familiar
with the image of the prisoner in the
snowstorm digging coal with a pickaxe
there were camps in central moscow where
prisoners built apartment blocks or
designed airplanes
there were camps in krasnoyarsk where
prisoners ran
nuclear power plants
there were fishing camps on the pacific
coast
i once had the chance to look at the
gulag photo albums these were albums put
together by the gulag administrators and
they included pictures of prisoners with
their camels in central asia and so from
actu binsk you know to yakutsk there was
not really a single major population in
the soviet union that did not have its
own local camp or camps and not a single
industry that did not employ prisoners
so over the years prisoners built roads
and railroads power plants and chemical
factories manufactured weapons furniture
they you know even children's toys
uh in the soviet union of the 1940s
which was in fact the decade that the
camps reached their zenith
it would have been very difficult in
many places to go about your daily
business and not run into prisoners
and it is therefore no longer possible
to argue as some once did that the camps
were known to only a small proportion of
the population
um we also understand better the
chronology of the camps so we've long
known that lenin built the first ones in
1918 so at the time of the bolshevik
revolution so the camps absolutely date
back to the very beginning
and originally they were a kind of ad
hoc emergency measure to contain enemies
of the people um which was a you know a
designation that meant you know enemies
of the revolution people we don't like
it could it could be it could be applied
to almost anybody again this is not a
system that has rule of law
um and of course they were designed to
prevent counter-revolution they also
were sometimes meant to re-educate the
bourgeoisie the opponents of the
bolsheviks
um we also have long known that stalin
and his success excuse me that lenin um
and his immediate successors expanded
the camps to the solevsky islands this
was the group of islands in the far
north uh in the white sea north of in
the northern part of russia in the 1920s
and that original expansion was again
initially for the political opponents of
the bolsheviks who were often other
socialists so social democrats or social
revolutionaries people who who the
bolsheviks found to be ideologically
threatening and they were initially put
in this group of camps on a there was a
monastery on the islands in the north
um
although that was initially a relatively
small operation
but the archives also helped us
understand why stalin chose to expand
them in 1929.
so in that year
stalin launched the five-year plan this
was an extraordinarily costly attempt
costly in both human lives and natural
resources to force a 20
annual increase in the soviet union's
industrial output so this and to
collectivize agriculture this was
stalin's attempt to push the soviet
union faster to modernize faster
and one of the side effects of the plan
was millions of arrests as peasants were
forced off their land maybe you'll
discuss that later in the course
and imprisoned if they refused
it also led to an enormous labor
shortage
suddenly the soviet union found itself
in need of coal gas and minerals
most of which could be found only in the
far
in the far north of the country
following a series of discussions
which used almost exclusively economic
language again i had the chance to read
as they were
as the leaders of the soviet union this
is after lenin's death this is now when
stalin is a leader um as they were
um discussing how to expand the camps um
i you know there's a there are records
of the conversations that that the
politburo had at that time the
leadership of the soviet union and
what's very striking about them is that
almost exclusively economic language is
being used so the decision is taken that
we need the prisoners to extract the
minerals
and of course to the secret policeman
who were charged with carrying out the
construction of the camps this made a
great deal of sense
so here is how alexei loginoff who is
the former deputy commander of the
norilsk camps these were north of the
arctic circle this is how he justified
the use of prisoner labor
um in a 1992 interview so many years
later he said
if we had sent civilians we would first
have had to build houses for them to
live in and how could civilians live
there with prisoners it is easy all you
need is a barrack a stove with a chimney
and they survive
so prisoners in gulag documents are
often referred to as contingent
contingents
from the point of view of the soviet
leadership and of camp commanders they
were an ingredient of production they
were like lumps of coal or bars of steel
you know enemies of the people didn't
need to live like civilians in normal
houses
they could be put in barracks didn't
really matter what happened to them if
there wasn't quite enough food for them
it wasn't a tragedy
they were both cheap and expendable they
weren't human they were they were
enemies they could be used in this way
which was very useful
for a country that wanted to modernize
very fast
that isn't to say that the camps in
addition to their economic function
which is as they say that's how they
were always described were not also
intended to terrorize and subjugate the
population
certainly prison and camp regimes that
were dictated in minute detail by moscow
were very openly designed to humiliate
and dehumanize prisoners so the
prisoners belts and buttons and garters
and items made of plastic were taken
away from them again they were described
as enemies they were forbidden to use
the word comrades which was only for
people you know full full fully paid-up
citizens of the state
and that again those kinds of measures
contributed to the dehumanization
their dehumanization in the eyes of
guards and bureaucrats who therefore
found it that much easier not to treat
them as fellow citizens or even as
fellow human beings
and in fact this turned out to be quite
a powerful ideological combination so
the disregarding of the humanity of
prisoners on the one hand combined with
the overwhelming need to fulfill the
plan
and nowhere is this clearer than in the
camp inspection reports these were
submitted periodically by local
prosecutors kept neatly on file in
moscow which is where i found them
when i first began to read them i was
actually quite shocked at first both by
their frankness and the peculiar kind of
outrage they express
so for example describing conditions in
volgolag this was a railroad
construction camp in tarterston in july
1942
one inspector complained that
the whole population of the camp
including free workers lives off flour
the only meal for prisoners is so-called
bread made with flour and water without
meats or fats and as a result the
inspector went on indignantly there was
a high rate of illness particularly
scurvy and not surprisingly the camp was
failing to meet its production norms so
this outrage you know you're mistreating
these prisoners
this ceased to seem surprising
after i had read several dozen similar
reports
each one of which used more or less the
same sort of language and each of which
ended with more or less the same ritual
conclusion you know conditions need to
be improved so that the prisoners will
work harder and so that the production
norms will be met
but very little was actually done so
while it might have been expected that
living conditions in the gulag were poor
during the war which as they were all
across the soviet union
a nationwide inspection for example of
23 large camps in 1948 still concluded
among other things that 75 percent of
the prisoners in norolag and norilsk had
no warm boots that the number of
prisoners unfit for hard labor and
corellia meaning they were too weak had
recently tripled that death rates were
still quote unquote too high in half a
dozen camps meaning that is too high to
allow for efficient production
um without question the expansion of the
camps distorted the soviet economy with
so much cheap labor available the soviet
economy took far longer than it should
have done to become mechanized this is
of course the irony
of stalin's modernization push you know
problems were solved by calling for more
workers
famously the white sea canal one of the
early gulag projects was built with
pickaxes even at a time when
more sophisticated equipment was
available
with so many
poorly trained people working under
coercion the construction was not of the
highest quality either
by one account labor productivity among
the free workers in the forestry
industry was nearly three times that of
prisoners um in the for working in the
forestry camps
um but the camps also distorted the way
that people in the lands of the former
soviet union thought about economics
this is a little diversion
but it's an interesting point which i
can illustrate by describing a trip that
i took a few years ago quite a few years
ago now to the city of vorkuta on the
arctic circle um vorkuta's history
begins in 1931 which is when a group of
colonists first arrived in the region by
boat up the northern waterways
although even the tsars had known about
the region's enormous coal reserves no
one had managed to work out precisely
how to get the coal out of the ground
given the real horror of life in a place
where temperatures regularly drop to
minus 30 or minus 40 in the winter where
the sun doesn't shine for six months of
the year and where in the summer which
is when i was there
the mosquitoes travel in these enormous
in these enormous dark clouds
but stalin found a way
by making use of another sort of vast
reserve vorkuta's original 23 settlers
were prisoners and the leaders of that
founding expedition were secret
policemen and over the subsequent two
and a half decades a million more
prisoners passed through vorkuta one of
the two or three most notorious hubs of
the gulag
with the help of prisoners the soviet
authorities built shops and swimming
pools and schools
um but the cost of heating these shoddy
soviet apartment blocks for 11 months of
the year turned out to be astronomical
far more than the value of the coal
itself
the city's infrastructure was which was
built on this constantly shifting
permafrost required huge efforts to
maintain
you know instead miners could have flown
in on two or three week shifts like they
do in alaska
um or in canada um you know there was no
there was no need to build the city
there
um nevertheless the city of vorkuta kept
going throughout the 1970s and 1980s and
1990s and many thousands of people still
live there today
um truth of course is that vorkuta is
unnecessary the city is unnecessary you
know why build kindergartens in a
university you know in the tundra why
build a puppet theater you know rokuta
had three
um but in volcute it was really
difficult to ask such questions even
after the ussr collapse and i have a
particularly strong memory of a day that
i spent there with a retired geologist
she was named zhenya and together we
walked around the city we went to the
prisoners cemeteries we went around the
ruins of the geological institute a once
solid structure complete with a columned
stalinist portico and a red star on the
pediment
zhenya's polish parents had been
arrested and deported there in the 1940s
and she knew that story of course
and she knew the city's history very
well
and nevertheless she was she railed
against you know what the people she
called the greedy bureaucrats who had
shut down the institute you know and who
were shutting down
those parts of the city that weren't
simply weren't economic to keep up
you know if your whole life has been
associated with a place
it is really hard to admit that that
place need never have existed or that it
won't exist in the future you know even
if that place is widely famed for
atrocity and stupidity even if it's
notoriously unpleasant
it is really hard to admit that it ought
not to have been built at all
um but if zhenya who was the daughter of
victims
uh was unable to understand you know the
the the strange economic situation of
her city and the and the role it played
in history
um then who can
um and this question brings me to the
next part of this talk in which i'd like
to ask
why the gulag
about which historians now know so much
you know since my book has been written
there have been many others um
there is a you know fantastic amount of
research that is that is widely
available and and whose economic impact
we understand so much better and whose
psychological impact we we understand as
well
why is it so seldom debated and
discussed by modern russians um and in
this i'll talk about the gulag in a
larger sense why is the gulag rarely
discussed why are stalin's crimes rarely
discussed
why is it so disappeared from from from
the modern russian debate
i mean one of the things
that always strikes contemporary
visitors to russia
is the lack of monuments to stalin's
victims so there are a few
scattered memorials but there's really
no
national monument or place of mourning
and the actually the absence of
monuments is an accurate reflection
of the absence of public debate
um i should say this was not always the
case
so there were wide-ranging discussion of
soviet repression in the 1980s this is
the very end of the soviet period during
the reign of mikhail gorbachev
and actually these discussions played an
important maybe key you know maybe
um you know absolutely central role in
delegitimizing the soviet regime so once
as i mentioned at the beginning of this
lecture all these subjects were kept in
you know they were heavily secret they
were not talked about while the soviet
union existed and in this outburst of
glasnost this moment when suddenly all
kinds of things were possible to talk
about in the 1980s one of the first
things that happened is people began
talking about this that you know the the
camp system and and the crimes of the
camp system the crimes of the stalin era
um and
you know people then began to ask you
know if this system that we're still
part of created this all these horrors
you know why should we support it
anymore
and as i say these were really important
discussions at a time
at the time but this debate the bitter
debate at the time about justice for the
victims is now completely over and it
really left no political institutions in
its wake
um and so although there was much talk
about it at the end of the 1980s the
russian government never did examine or
try the perpetrators of torture or mass
murder even those who were still alive
or identifiable
there were no truth commissions there
was no national debate you know
of the kind implemented in south africa
which might have allowed victims to tell
their stories in an official public
sphere in a public venue
um
there were no you know there was
certainly no compensation for victims
you know at some level
the reasons for this are are not hard to
fathom
even by 1990 91 the stalinist era had
been long past the the last stalinist
camps closed in the in the after stalin
died in the 1950s
there had been a smaller camp camp
system just for political prisoners that
lasted right up to the end of the soviet
union has now been revived under putin
but the era of mass incarceration had
been over for a long time and a great
deal had happened since it had ended
post-soviet russia was not the same as
post-soviet germany where memories of
the worst atrocities were still very
much present in people's minds
the memories of the camps is also
confused in russia by the presence of so
many other atrocities to the other
things to remember you know the war
um the famines um collectivization
uh the mass murder you know why should
camp survivors get some kind of
privileged status or treatment
um
i think the
you know in a way the the
the problem is made even more confusing
by the link that was made in some
people's minds um between that
discussion of the past that took place
in the 1980s which i've mentioned
and the collapse of the economy in the
1990s
so people would say people used to say
this to me in russia
what was the point of talking about all
of that you know it didn't get us
anywhere
um there's also kind of question of
pride you know like
zhenya uh many people experienced the
collapse of the soviet union as a kind
of personal blow you know it it altered
their identity you know their world made
no sense after it was gone who were they
what was their nationality
but also perhaps the old system was bad
they might have felt but at least we
were powerful and important
and now that we are not powerful we
really don't want to hear that it was
bad still i think that the most
important explanation for the lack of
debate
and here i'm going to be interested i i
would be interested to hear how you're
going to compare this to the american
experience
the most important explanation for the
lack of debate
is not really the fears and anxieties of
ordinary russians but it was really to
do with the nature of the country's new
ruling class who remain the current
ruling class
so vladimir putin who's the president of
russia is a former kgb officer who has
described himself using the word
czechist which is a word that lenin used
for the political police um
uh you know famously
putin has also described the breakup of
the soviet union as the greatest
political geopolitical catastrophe of
the 20th century presumably meaning
greater than world wars 1 or 2.
so under his watch soviet flags have
returned to anniversary parades um the
soviet national anthem has been revived
soviet symbolism of all kinds have been
reside
has been brought back
and his this intent the reason for this
is quite clear so putin is trying to
create
an alternate version of post-soviet
history one which
supports his claims to rule the country
so
by his version of the past 1991 which is
the year the soviet union broke up was
not a moment of liberation
it was the beginning of economic
collapse
the hardships and deprivations of the
1990s were not the result of decades of
communist neglect and widespread theft
but of western style democracy and
communism was stable and safe
post-communism was a disaster
the soviet union was great you know
russia at least until putin took over
was a failure
the more people believe that version of
history
the less likely they are to want a
system that is more genuinely democratic
and which offers people um real
opportunities to advance which isn't a
you know a top-down controlled
kleptocracy
the more nostalgia but on the on the
contrary the more nostalgia for the
soviet era um the more secure
putin and his kind of xkgb clique is
likely to be
um
so in other words the failure to discuss
the past or dwell on the past or repent
the past or
focus on the past is a part of this
redirecting of history towards the
political needs of the present rulers um
but it has also had consequences for the
formation of russian civil society and
for the development of rule of law
it helps explain for example why
russians
are not as bothered as they should be by
certain kinds of censorship or by the by
the new
tactic of naming any you know
independent journalists as enemies of
the state they're now called foreign
agents but it's the same idea
um or why um why the you know when the f
when the fsb which is the modern
incarnation of the kgb when they are
when they are given free reign to open
mail or tap telephones or enter private
residences why without a court order why
there's not more objection to this
um
you know the the sense that there needed
to be a break with the old system that
the lack of rule of law demands a
profound change um never really happened
um i think there's a kind of deeper
significance too
you know to put it
bluntly um if the scoundrels of the old
regime all went unpunished
um there was no
you know there was no justice in the in
the new system and so
this you know good good didn't triumph
after 1991 and this may sound a little
bit apocalyptic but it's not politically
irrelevant so
after 1991
the when the soviet union broke up the
secret policemen the leaders of the old
system they kept their apartments their
dutches their country houses their large
pensions
and their victims the former prisoners
remained poor and marginal
and so to most russians it now seems as
if the more you collaborated in the past
the wiser you were you know
um you know the you know if you were if
you were a winner then you're a winner
now
um and by analogy you know the more you
cheat and lie and stay within the system
in the present the wiser you are now too
um the the that there's no benefit from
justice there's no you don't gain
anything from
um from seeking redress for past crimes
um personally what bothers me the most
about russia's lack of interest in this
part of its past is the way it's
deprived young people of some of their
heroes
so the names of those who secretly
oppose stalin ought to be as widely
known in russia as they are in germany
for example as the names of the
participants in the plot to kill hitler
you know the incredibly rich body of
russian survivors literature which i use
to write my book you know these are
tales of people whose humanity triumphed
over horrifying conditions and
you know there's amazing stories of
friendship and bravery you know these
should be better read and better known
and more frequently quoted
i if if school children knew these
heroes and their stories better they
would find something to be proud of in
russia's soviet past aside from imperial
and military triumphs
you know this after all this is the
country that invented the modern human
rights movement and yet i don't think
most russians think of that or remember
it you know instead
that part of russia's past remains very
closed and so
almost like a kind of unopened pandora's
box um it lies in wait
for the next generation
um but do we
in the u.s or in europe do we remember
the soviet past which is a part of
soviet history it's a part of world
history
do we remember it any better
one of the reasons i wrote my gulag book
this is one of my inspirations
in the late 1990s was because i really
encountered this subject myself
only while living in eastern europe i
remember the first person i met who was
a who had been a gulag prisoner was in
vilnius in lithuania it was a
man who explained to me how
you could pack lots of people into the
back of a truck because he remembered
how how it had been done
um in in the ear in the 1940s when he
was deported along with his family
um but this subject wasn't taught in my
school um even though i studied russian
history at yale
it wasn't the subject of great interest
you know it wasn't it wasn't part of any
major part of any curriculum you know we
didn't have a course like the one
um professor snyder and stanley are
teaching
um today um
you know the gulag when i was growing up
was was not really part of popular
culture either the way that nazi camps
were you know people had you have an
image in your mind of what a nazi camp
looks like but not of a gulag camp
but it wasn't really part of standard
histories of the 20th century it just
wasn't a subject that you encountered
um
and i you know i i spent a lot of time
thinking about why that was as well and
i i felt once again it was possible to
explain this absence of popular feeling
about the tragedy of european communism
also there were some logical
explanations again the passage of time
was part of it
communist regimes also grew less
reprehensible as time went on
nobody was very afraid of general
yarazelski who was the last dictator
communist dictator of poland nobody was
you know as frightened of the and the
final soviet leaders even brezhnev and
drop off as much as they were frightened
of stalin although both were responsible
for a great deal of destruction
but besides as i said the archives were
closed
access to campsites was forbidden
no television cameras ever filmed the
soviet camps or their victims
as they had done
in germany at the end of the second
world war and no images in turn meant
that the subject in our image-driven
culture didn't really exist either
to this day it's very difficult to make
documentaries about the gulag because
there just aren't photographs there
aren't pictures
but ideology also shaped the way in
which we understood soviet and east
european history as well for as long as
that system existed
and this is an interesting point that
again you'll find
might might have further echoes in the
in the course that you're doing
um in europe and the us you can actually
trace the ups and downs of knowledge of
the soviet union so
at different times people knew more or
less about it at different times the
story figured more or less in the
popular press
in other words the the politics of the
west the politics of europe the politics
of the united states actually affected
the way we understood soviet politics
so for example
in the 1920s
a great deal was known in western
capitals in berlin in london and in
washington
about the bloodiness of lenin's
revolution
and that was because in the first
victims as i as i mentioned already of
the revolution were socialists um and
western socialists so in again in all
the in all the important capitals um
knew that their brother and their
comrades had been jailed by the
bolsheviks and they the first people to
really protest loudly and strongly
against the crimes being completed being
committed by the by the revolution were
was were on the left
um
however in the 1930s as americans and
west europeans became more interested in
learning how socialism could be applied
at home you know this is a time of
economic crisis in the west and people
were looking for other solutions
the tone changes and then american
and european writers go off to the ussr
and they try to use to learn
lessons that could be that could be
brought back
famously some of what later became
uh franklin roosevelt's kitchen cabinet
went to the soviet union to see if there
was something they could learn
the new york times at that time employed
a correspondent walter durante who
lauded the five-year plan um and argued
against a lot of evidence that it was a
massive success
uh he also argued that collectivization
was not a disaster and he he covered up
the stories of the famine especially in
ukraine even though he knew they were
true and he won a pulitzer prize for
doing so because this is what people
wanted to hear there was a moment when
people didn't want to hear any more
about why the revolution was bad they
wanted to hear what was succeeding or
what was they thought was success
throughout the 1930s and 40s
a part of um i would say it's not even
the western left i mean i would say
mainstream
western politicians struggled to explain
and sometimes excuse the camps because
you know stories would filter through
and the terror that created them
precisely because they wanted to try
some aspects of the soviet experiment at
home so our politics shaped our
understanding of the soviet union um and
this became even more complicated
during the second world war
when stalin was our ally
so in 1944
the american vice president henry
wallace actually went to kolima which is
one of the most notorious camps during a
trip across the ussr which he said
reminded him of the wild wild west
there's a famous quote where he says you
know soviet asia reminds me so much of
my homeland
um according to a report that the boss
of kulima later wrote for beria who was
then the head of the secret services
soviet secret services wallace did ask
to see prisoners so he knew where he was
he knew he was seeing
a site of mass incarceration
but he was kept away from them
he was not alone in not wanting to know
this piece of truth this this
this aspect of the soviet system i mean
obviously at that moment roosevelt and
churchill were meeting regularly with
stalin
um they had their photographs taken with
him they were they were they saw him as
an ally in their war against hitler and
so they were simply not interested in
bringing up this this subject
um
all of that is part of what contributed
to our
firm conviction that the second world
war was a holy just war
and even today very few people want that
conviction shaken so we remember d-day
we remember the liberation of the nazi
concentration camps we remember
children welcoming american gis with
cheers on the streets
and we don't remember that the camps of
stalin our ally expanded into eastern
europe this is the topic of my book that
tim mentioned
um
on the on the expansion of the soviet
system into into into poland and
czechoslovakia and hungary and we don't
remember that those camps expanded
um just as the camps of hitler our enemy
were liberated so nobody wants to think
that we defeated one mass murderer with
the help of another
during the cold war it's true our
awareness of soviet atrocities went up
again again this reflected american
politics and american political needs
rather than anything that was happening
in the ussr
in the 1960s
they receded again
even in the 1980s when i was at yale
there were still american academics who
would describe the advantages of east
german health care or polish peace
initiatives they would try to push the
the values of these systems
um and in at the time when i was an
undergraduate in the academic world
soviet historians who wrote about the
can you know kind of generally divided
into two groups
those who wrote about the camps as
criminal and they were kind of right
called right wing and those who
downplayed them if not because they were
actually pro-soviet but because they
were opposed to america's role in the
cold war or maybe ronald reagan you know
in other words the one's attitude
towards the soviet union was very often
and its camps was very often shaped by
one's own politics and i'm i'm saying
this neutrally i'm not saying that one
side was bad or good but your your view
of the ussr was was shaped by your view
of america in the cold war and really
right up until the very end of the cold
war um our views of the soviet union and
its repressive system always had more to
do with american politics and american
ideological struggles than they did with
the soviet union itself i mean it's a
lesson that the
you know we see things through through
the lens of our own time and we we found
it difficult to talk about this subject
in a neutral way
while the soviet union still existed um
i should add that it you know there are
people who maintain that this is still
true i i actually don't think so i think
it's now possible you know as as as tim
snyder does as many others do to write
about soviet history in a way that's
not doesn't reflect your views about
america or the cold war or reagan um
it's now uh because the soviet union
doesn't exist anymore because it's part
of history you can write about it in a
neutral way and one of the reasons
there's so much good soviet scholarship
in the last years is because the
ideology is gone the struggle is gone
and now we can see we can begin to see
the system
for what it was
so as i said since the collapse of the
soviet union in 1991 much has changed
world war ii
really now definitively belongs to a
previous generation
the cold war is over
the alliances and the international
fault lines that it produced have
shifted for good
uh the western left and the western
right if you can even use those terms
anymore they now compete over different
issues and so finally it's become
possible to stop looking at the history
of the soviet union through the narrow
lens of western politics
and i'll finish by saying that it's not
only possible i believe it's necessary
i'm really glad that there's another
generation of students who will who will
investigate this story who will interest
themselves in it because after all
in an important sense the gulag is part
of our history too
uh why did we fight the cold war after
all you know was it because some crazy
right-wing politicians in cahoots with
the military-industrial complex and the
cia because they invented the whole
thing and they forced two generations of
americans to go along with it
or was something you know was there
something more important happening
um i'm not sure we still remember what
it was that mobilized us what kept us
together what held the civilization of
the west together for so long and
and and what the useful part of that
story was and what we achieved by doing
that
but of course it's also the case that
the history of the gulag belongs in a
much broader sense to the history of
mankind
every one of the 20th century's mass
tragedies was unique
the gulag the holocaust the armenian
massacre
the nan king massacre the cultural
revolution the cambodian revolution the
bosnian wars
every one of these events had different
historical and philosophical origins
they all arose in circumstances that
will never be repeated
but it is our ability to debase and
destroy and once again dehumanize our
fellow men this is something that can
and will be
repeated again and again it's our
ability to transform our neighbors or
our fellow citizens into enemies
our reinvention of our victims as lower
or lesser or evil beings we're the only
of incarcer incarceration or expulsion
or forced labor or sometimes death um
these things are repeated again and
again
um and the more that we are able to
understand how different societies have
have have accomplished this how they
have transformed their neighbors and
fellow citizens into objects the more we
know of the specific circumstances of
each episode of
mass murder or of mass dehumanization
the more that we will understand
um the nature of of you know human
nature itself
um you know i wrote my book about the
gulag not so that it will not happen
again
which is how the cliche goes and because
it will happen again it has happened
again
and i think we need to know why
and each story each memoir
you know each document is a piece of the
puzzle
if we don't have them
we will wake up one day and realize that
we don't know who we are
so thank you very much i look forward to
your questions um
it's been a pleasure speaking to
yale and new haven
residents once again
and thank you thank you very much that
was that was that was wonderful and that
was terrific and we're going to have a
lively discussion now i realized that in
my in my introduction
i made at least two mistakes um number
number one was i forgot to tell our
audience that they're supposed to be
asking questions
so this is this is a webinar and if you
all look at the at your bottom at the
bottom of the screen to the to the sort
of center right there's a thing called q
a
where i believe if you type in your
question i'll be able to see it and then
i'll be able as moderator to pass it on
to pass it on to tan apple belm um oh my
gosh yeah the raising hand thing isn't
going to work though so i see that some
of you are raising your hand it would be
cool if instead you would use the q a
function as one of you just did okay
great we're off to we're off to a good
start um my second mistake is that i
forgot to mention that that anne is a
yale graduate um but unfortunately she
rescued me by mentioning it six times
during the talk um and she's all oh
sorry okay twice um she rescued me i
mentioned it during the talk um that's
all the more reason we're happy to have
you as it were
back um and and we'll hope to have you
back again
i'm gonna i'm gonna buy a little time to
as the questions accumulate and maybe
professor stanley will want to do the
same and join us just by by giving you a
couple of broad questions um to to think
about um
and you can just you can just pick if
any of these any of these strike you was
interesting they have to do with themes
that have already begun to emerge in in
the class and which you've you've put a
name on to
um
i i was i was in kiev
um this weekend
and i was in kiev to talk about this
strange uh sort of open letter that
vladimir putin wrote about ukraine and
its history
and um this may seem very far apart from
what we're working on in this class and
it may be the influence of this class on
me that i read it this way
but so mr putin wrote this long letter
as some of you will know
um basically making the historical case
that the ukrainian nation doesn't exist
and concluding that as a result it's up
to russia to decide whether ukraine is
sovereign or not and as i was reading
this i mean i i read this and i was
asked to make a public critique of it
and that's why i was in kiev and i said
a number of things but one thing which
is on my mind which i didn't say
was that
when i read this particular form of
history that's the right word i was
struck by how much it reminded me of
white supremacy
like that that what what mr putin was
doing was basically saying he was
telling other people what their history
was
and telling them
that uh they didn't really have a voice
in it and that he had the final word in
what and what had happened and like in a
very broad way um that's like that's a
way in which like i think just beginning
to teach this class has has helped me to
make connections because i wouldn't i
wouldn't have thought of that if it
hadn't been for this class but if you
read the letter and i'm going to
recommend to the students that you do
read this letter because it's a it's a
striking example of how
of a kind of a history that's so
one-sided where one person doesn't see
any problem in saying you were happy
everything was fine nothing nothing was
wrong but this leads me to something to
a theme which is in your book um and in
your other work but didn't come out so
much in the lecture so maybe i'll just
ask you about it
and that's that's the theme of ethnicity
and nationality
it's um it's it's very striking as you
know that at particular moments
especially around collectivization and
then at the end of the second world war
that ukrainians and also during the
period of political prisoners in the
1970s ukrainians are vastly
overrepresented
in the camps
and so i'm i'm wondering if you would
and you mentioned your you mentioned
your friend zhenya you know who was who
is polish and whose parents probably
called her genka um and the polls were
also vastly overrepresented they were a
tiny minority but they were vastly
overrepresented in the camps and in the
shootings
i wonder how at the end at the end of
your research you think about this i
mean how if it's if it's an economic you
know if it's if it's a if it's it's on
the surface economic and but then it
it's also about punishment
why do we explain you know in the system
which is supposed to be after all
internationalist how do we explain that
certain kinds of people end up being
punished in such obviously greater
numbers than others
thanks that's um it's a
it's a great question because one of the
old cliches about the soviet union used
to be that well you know the nazis
killed people for racial reasons and the
soviet union killed people for class
reasons
and one of the other
impacts one of the other things you get
from reading soviet archives which me
and many other people have done
since 1990
is is the extent to which that's not
true becomes clear um so what what the
soviet union did was what what's what
stalin soviet union did was it
identified potential enemies you know
who might be our opposition who might be
in opposition to the state
um and there were different and and and
there were different qualities that
could make someone an enemy and one of
the qualities was if you were a former
russian aristocrat or if you were a
former military officer and so on but
another quality that made you a
potential enemy was being from a
potentially enemy ethnic group
and actually the great the so-called
great terror of 1937 and 1938 begins
with and we again we know this is now
documented begins with a purge of polls
and so all over the soviet union i mean
there's not a there's not a there's not
millions of millions and many there are
many but there are many
there are many polish citizens of
because of the way the borders have
moved over history because
um because part of what was once poland
later became russia and so on there are
a number of ethnically polish citizens
living in the ussr in the in the 1930s
even then and there's a purge of them
they're arrested on mass
um you know anybody with a polish
surname becomes liable for arrest um and
then a similar you know there's a
there's a
you know sim there's a similar effect
that affects ukrainians a little bit
later on um ukraine is a little bit
different it's it's bigger there's
actually ukrainian
um you know a ukrainian um
uh you know uh republic within the
soviet union um but the ukrainians you
know as you know and as you've written
about and i've also written about are
then targeted in a different way um
they're deprived of food um in the early
1930s um and deliberately left to starve
um because that then you know eliminates
this problem of ukraine that stalin
perceives ukraine as a problem because
you know the the ukrainians haven't
entirely accepted the soviet ideology so
so what you see is that ethnicity
becomes one of the
you know it i mean and it's not as if
the
you know the polls who arrested in 1937
or the ukraines were murdered in 1933
it's not as if anybody has really
examined
whether these people are pro or
anti-soviet or what their political
views are they're targeted because
nationality and ethnicity have become a
kind of symbolic marker
you know they don't
you know they're they're used as ah you
are this therefore you're probably an
enemy you know you are your your
nationality is a kind of identifying
qual you know quality um and when we are
seeking to eliminate all enemies when
we're seeing you to cleanse the system
to make you know to make sure that only
our people are inside it one of the
markers that's used is that um and all
through the soviet union i mean they're
different as you know there are
different phases there are different
moments when different ethnic groups are
targeted um and actually at the end of
stalin's life he began targeting jews
this is the famous so-called doctor's
plot was beginning at a widespread
investigation of jews in the system and
many jews were fired and this actually
even had a an echo in the
some of the satellite states and the
czech republics actually wasn't called
the czech republic then it was
czechoslovakia um in czechoslovakia
there was a purge of jews as well there
was an echo of the of the soviet version
so different ethnic groups could be
isolated and picked on
um and eliminated um as a way of
fulfilling this anxiety the system had
about itself i mean i i really do think
putin's you know putin is anxious about
ukraine i don't mean in its kind of
freudian psychological way i mean he's
he's he's anxious for a reason um
because ukraine
poses a challenge to russia today and
it's the same kind of challenge ukraine
posed to stalin
namely
um
it's a
you know it's a it's a country that is
closely related ethnically to russia
um yet it doesn't accept it entire
doesn't accept the i the ruling ideology
of russia it wants to be different in
ukraine modern ukraine's case it wants a
more democratic less kleptocratic
political system you know in the 1930s
ukraine wanted some of its own national
status and language and the and the
reaction of the totalitarian of the
autocrat of the authoritarian
is to eliminate as you say either
eliminate the history or eliminate the
reality of these opposing nations um and
it's a it's a it's a it's a character
trait that you can i don't you know
putinism is not stalinism they aren't
the same thing at all but there are
these
these these echoes you know from the
past and to the present um uh that you
know in which the
the you know anybody who's seen is
outside of our group anybody who offers
an alternative view of the world
has to be eliminated or denied agency or
removed of their history um because
they're a threat to the mainstream i
mean that's so so in that sense um
it's it's actually you know it's a
really important theme all the way
through the soviet union not something
that i think was sufficiently understood
you know we believed their language
about internationalism and so on and
class warfare
and while the soviet union existed it
was much harder to see exactly how
racist it was
okay so
you do you want to come in we've got a
bunch of questions now so so we're good
if you want to come in first please do
yeah i'm just going to say that one of
the questions of our seminar is how
do prison systems become massive
what are the elements the core elements
that result in the kind of enormous
prison systems you see say in the united
states now in the soviet union and
whether say and whether ethnicity
targeting an ethnic group is necessary
for that mass structure um or at least
always implicated um so you certainly
need an element of
dehumanization in other words you have
to
you know in the soviet union it's not
only ethnic it can be ethnic and it was
often ethic but it wasn't only ethnic um
but you need to
have identified some group as less
worthy or they aren't real citizens or
they aren't the same as the rest of us
or they are
you know they are somehow deserving of
being locked up on mass they aren't part
of the same they don't have the same
status the same citizenship as us
um and that can be ethnic or or racial
and has often been but it does it's not
only that um
you know so as i said the the moment of
mass expansion in the soviet union
is also this moment of collectivization
for those who don't know that's the
moment when
um
peasants were forced to leave their
private farms and forced onto these
collective farms and many resisted they
didn't want to do this they didn't want
to give up their cow to the collective
and they were worried they would starve
which actually
they did they were right to worry um and
so there was a mass arrest of peasants
they were called kulaks they were given
a special name anybody who resisted i
mean it was supposed to be rich peasants
but actually anyone who resisted
collectivization was named kulak and
they were liable to arrest and and
alongside this campaign to arrest them
there was a massive propaganda effort to
dehumanize the kulaks the kulaks are
preventing the revolution the kulaks are
opposed to the rest of us you know there
would be caricatures of the evil kulak
with you know a long beard and sort of
evil eyes and scary-looking faces that
you would find in the you know in the
soviet press and there would be and that
kind of you know they would be
associated with you know the white
guards and the aristocrats and the
whatever satan and the devil i mean
almost anything they would be they were
they were they were they were made into
enemies and that was both
and that allowed the guards to accept
you know the fact that they were there
and it also
allowed the rest of the population to
accept these mass arrests so obviously
you know if you're surrounded by
evil people who are seeking to overthrow
the state and ruin your revolution
you know and they're they're the ones
who are preventing us from achieving
full communism and
you know i don't know manna and honey
and milk and honey for everybody these
are the people standing in the way of
course you're willing to remove them
um and there's an echo of this i mean i
spent a little bit when i was writing
the gulag book and there's a little bit
similar in the ukraine book um
i spent a lot of time looking at how the
guards talked about the prisoners you
know what's the way they spoke about
them and it was exact i mentioned this
in the speech but i'll just emphasize it
you know they are
they are seen as lumps of coal they are
they aren't they have no humanity i mean
when people are outraged that they're
starving it's not because they're hungry
people but because how do you expect us
to fulfill the production quotas with
these starving people they're too weak
to work in other words the
the system successfully removes them
they aren't citizens they aren't like us
they deserve to be in this prison
um you know and and that can that can
doesn't have to be ethnic it can also
racial it can also be political i mean
you can politicize any group in fact
um and make it into an enemy group um
you don't even need to have ethnic and
racial differences
okay i'm gonna if it's all right i'm
gonna go ahead and just read some of
some of some of these some of these
thoughtful questions that we have
um
so
um
with the convention by the way to all of
you who are watching is that i'm not
gonna give the names of people who are
asking the questions so i'm just i'm
just going to give the question so a
question is
um and i'm also going to skip the part
when you say how great a lecture it is
i'm going to skip that part i'm going to
go right to the question
i was really surprised this is a
question i was really surprised that
more of russian society doesn't talk
about the gulags given how extensively
the system had impacted the lives of
many under the stalin era my question is
about public and social memory i was
curious about the differences between
russians who had experiences with
incarceration and those who did not
could you tell us more about your
conversations with them that is people
who had been incarcerated
how did they remember the gulag
differently did the perception and
language of those who had been
incarcerated
challenged the wider amnesia denial in
wider russian society or was there a
similar cognitive dissonance
that's a it's it's it's a more it's a
trickier question to answer now than it
was really frankly 30 years ago 25 years
ago when i was working on the book i
mean we now the generation of people who
i interviewed aren't there anymore and
so this isn't a
living question in the same way that it
was a few decades ago because
most of the
you know most gulag survivors are no
longer with us i mean it's enough time
has
enough time has passed
um i mean it's a it's a question that's
complicated by politics because
um
as i said while the gulag existed
everybody knew about it it wasn't i mean
it was a secret and not a secret a
little bit the way the famine in ukraine
was a secret but not a secret so you
couldn't not know you know you everybody
lived in communities where there were
prisoners everybody you know if we're
talking about arrests of 10 or 15 of the
population then everybody has a cousin
or a friend or a relative everyone knew
that someone had been arrested so the
lack of
you know it and it raises an interesting
question about what is knowledge and
when do people know things and what do
we mean by public memory because
everyone knew and yet it was not allowed
to be discussed or wasn't
you weren't you weren't able to discuss
it and so the way that conversations
about the gulag worked is that in very
private little circles people did talk
about it and so there's a famous circle
that developed around evgenia ginsberg
who was a very it was a famous gulag
survivor in moscow
and she she was a sort of
proto-dissident really before there were
dissidents
and she gathered around herself a lot of
people who would come and would talk
about it and their friends and relatives
would know about it and they would you
know and and they and they were able to
speak about it freely and their children
would know about it and i've met some of
their children
um
and their you know their people in their
immediate circle would know um and then
there would be
other people in other circles who would
never speak about it again they would
come home and never talk so actually the
real distinction
wasn't between people who were there and
people who weren't there the real
distinction was between people who who
because of the politics and the
culture of their particular community
were able to speak about it and those
who weren't i mean so i so in
interviewing people you've got very
different reactions i have one
one or two people i interviewed in the
1990s who were still really too
frightened to speak about it i mean they
would very didn't much want to say
you know very clammed up nervous talking
to me what are you going to do with this
information if i tell you
why why do you have a tape recorder so
even then there were people who were
afraid and then there were people who
you would ask them one question they
would speak for you know four hours in
fact sometimes that was a problem um as
anybody who's ever done oral history or
you know who knows you know you had to
kind of get them back onto the thing you
you really needed them to speak about
so the difference was
you know the difference was that there
were
pockets of the society where
it was okay to speak about these things
in private and then there were other
pockets where it wasn't
and why that was that could be it could
be to do with fear it could be to do
with status you know the higher status
you were in the soviet system the less
you were likely to want to discuss these
things um it could be to do with
personalities um and so the so so so the
so the memory of it really depended on
humor and there's and something like
that persists today so
um you can still go to moscow and you
can meet people who know a lot about
russian history and will speak about it
at great length there are some great
russian historians who write in russian
it's not as if there's no research done
on this subject i mean actually all the
best historians are russians um the
really good ones i think you're reading
oleg volkov you know they're they're
they're
you know they're really they're really
the ones who really know the most um are
russians there are a couple of russian
institutions there are a few publishing
houses my bulldog book has been
published in russia very very small i
think 500 copies or something but it was
translated um so so there is a kind of
community of people which speaks about
it it's not totally illegal
um but what there isn't
it's not part of public discussion or
debate it's not
you know i'm guessing that depending on
the teacher it might occasionally appear
in a school curriculum
but there isn't a memorial there isn't
an annual celebration or you know like
there is holocaust day or holodomor day
in ukraine um there isn't a
um
you know there isn't a um
you know it's not part of the national
narrative um putin rewrote the national
narrative to focus on not on the gulag
not on stalin not on the dissidents not
on the human rights movement but on um
1945 which was the year of the greatest
soviet domination of europe and the
victory in the war and so every year now
there's an annual parade that mimics
these victory parade that they had in
1945 and and so somehow this story gets
left out of the picture
um and so again it's not illegal it's
not impossible
it's just not it's just not present in
public culture and public culture is
very heavily controlled by the state so
there isn't
a culture of independent universities
who can
argue with the public culture there
isn't a cult you know there aren't i
mean there are independent
magazines and newspapers but they're
increasingly repressed and marginalized
quite a lot of them are based outside of
russia now
the journalists have difficulty making
themselves heard
and actually there's a famous case going
on right now there is a gulag historian
he was a sort of amateur historian and
archaeologist
from corellia which is who and who i
actually met while i was working on the
book and who i whose family i've been in
touch with um who is now under arrest
and he's under arrest on some
false pretenses to do with supposedly
child pornography i mean it's a
completely trumped-up fake case but the
real reason he's under arrest is because
he's a public historian who spoke about
these issues and was very much
associated with them and petrosavats
which is the town that he comes from um
so
so you can be
people who are too loud about these
things can get in trouble
um some people continue in private
circles to speak about it but it's not
part of what putin wants people to think
of when they think about the history of
russia
so this this this question this
epistemic question like
as you said what it means to actually
know about something and
how knowledge comes out and how it might
have a political effect is something
which is on the minds of i think a
number
a number of the students
you referred in directly to
the chronicle of current events in
russia and the the attempt by you know
russians and ukrainians and others to
just write down the simplest details but
abundant details of what they could
learn about there's a lot about the
chronicle of current events in the book
yeah yeah this is something that this is
the theme which is which is going to
emerge over the course the class i have
a question which is about it so i'm just
going to i'm going to read it to you
you said that the gulag
is rarely discussed today but that when
it was the conversation delegitimized
the soviet regime
um so now we're going to move slowly now
into into some comparative questions um
because the the student is wondering how
this works in the u.s we've had repeated
societal conversations about mass
incarceration especially last year
do you think this public debate has
delegitimized institutions like
presidents genuinely or superficially if
the latter what's missing in the public
dialogue
that i don't know that i'm competent to
answer because i haven't spent a lot of
time thinking about this question in the
u.s i mean
but it's certainly it's certainly true
that conversation about mass
incarceration has
you know i mean for example
the criminal justice bill passed in the
clint you know by in the during the
clinton presidency which is now held to
be responsible for
for mass arrests
um was for a long time by a pretty wide
range of people thought to be
a good piece of legislation that you
know it was a it was something that
clinton himself would have taken credit
for at the time that it was passed and
quite a lot of people actually by the
way black and white i mean it had a lot
of pretty you know support
retrospectively
it's now heavily criticized and is now
seen as the source of this you know
unfair arrests or unfair prison
sentences
um and you know it is and it is you know
and even things like the you know in a
similar way
laws on marijuana i think are now
retrospectively seen as overly harsh and
ridiculously you know
punitive given
you know given that americans drink so
much anyway
um but
you know so so one thing the
conversation is does i mean i wouldn't
say that it's delegitimized
the political system but it certainly
delegitimized the assumptions that led
to this process so do we really need
this laws was this the right way to do
it um certainly and maybe jason you can
you can speak to this more eloquently
than i can i mean certainly
um the conversation about police reform
police brutality
um has been bumped up i think and
probably
you know also given energy by this
question of you know are too many people
in prison you know have too many people
been locked up so
you know you know so the so the
conversation you know having this be
part of the public conversation does
begin to affect the way people see the
police the way people see the criminal
justice system the way people see these
um these laws
you know the you know laws on um
whatever three strikes and you're out
the various
the various um uh laws that led to
larger and longer prison sentences so
yes i mean i think the public
conversation in that sense did
delegitimize that part of the criminal
justice system
but
not my area of expertise so would like
to hear jason talk about it
i mean in in in fairness it's there are
a few people who are capable of talking
about both these things at the same time
and that's one of the reasons why the
why we're doing this exploratory course
you know i mean the point is not that
jason and i know everything about both
systems and we're going to lay it out
there the point is that we have these
two really interesting phenomena and
we're going to we're going to put that
we're going to juxtapose and we're going
and we're going to learn as we go from
people it's like it's like comparing the
the holocaust and the and the gulag
they're not the same you know but but
it's interesting to talk about them
together so yeah no some people have
even written books where they're
together you know i don't know anyone
but some yeah there's probably probably
somebody out there somewhere um
so
i'm i'm gonna
there's a there's an important
substantive question here we're going
back to russia um and then maybe we'll
do a little more comparison
was there continuity between punishment
or incarceration in tsarist russia
before 1917
through the development of mass
incarceration the gulag in the next
decades
and this is another student asked this
question as well was there continuity
between the gulag and post-soviet
russia
right um so the answer is kind of
kind of yes and kind of yes um
the
you know the the the zara system um
um was actually you know retrospectively
relatively mild um
if you look at the numbers of people of
political prisoners there in the few few
hundreds or few thousands i think at the
time of
um at the beginning of the revolution
there were a few thousand political
prisoners which is by comparison to the
millions who were imprisoned by stalin
is is very low and the system was very
loose in fact it was so famously loose
that stalin escaped i think three times
from russian places of exile
um which is sort of amusing if you think
about it you know so and one of his you
know
it was so easy to escape from russian
prisons that he decided that when he was
finally in charge he was going to make
sure that
um they weren't so he was gay from again
um so there were substantive differences
in scale and and but there were a few
things i mean so the the idea of sending
prisoners to the far north and the far
east
um this was this was a czarist idea
um the idea that prisoners should
somehow be used to exploit these coal
mines or
you know gold mines in the in the
distant tundra this was also a czarist
idea so the tsars also had the idea that
you could use prisoners for these
things that were very difficult to
achieve
using you know normal people
and so this was something that the the
bolsheviks picked up this was an element
of continuity
um
also the other element of continuity was
the idea that you could send prisoners
to settle empty places you know this
that there was all this empty space in
the soviet union and we need to somehow
fill it and nobody wants to go there
because it's too many mosquitoes and too
cold you know so we can send prisoners
there to do it
and that has a that idea is continuous
all the way through and some of the
places i mean
um some of the places of exile in the
russian tsarist era and the soviet era
are the same
um and so and so that so there is a
there is a kind of continuity of
thinking about this so stalin didn't
make up the idea that you could use
prisoners to dig coal in the far north i
mean that was a that was an older idea
and then i would also say that the
you know this is similarity not of the
prisons but of the
of the systems in that the lack of rule
of law you know the
the fact was that the ruler could decide
what the law was and what the sentence
was
at any given moment
and that that could change depending on
political circumstances this is a
continuity this is continuous between
tsarist russia and stalin's russia so
there's no
there's no independent court system you
know there's no independent way of
making law or of overseeing prison
sentences you know the the you know the
czar suddenly decides that this group of
people you know in the case of i don't
know the decemberist uprising this group
of people deserve especially harsh
sentences and he could decide that they
would get them and that's a that's a
similarity to the soviet system and then
that's that's that's an element of
continuity that you have today so now
in the soviet union now i would say in
the 90s and early 2000s
it was fair to say that the gulag system
had ended there wasn't a system of
political prisons in russia
there is now beginning to be that again
um there are beginning to be people who
are sentenced for purely political
crimes um and are put in
um they're put in
you know in in i mean there are still
prison camps very and very often they're
in the same place
as the soviet camp so i was once in a
prison in arkhangelsk okay of all places
i went this is again this is about early
2000s i would say
i was in the prison it was a modern
russian prison this was not a political
prison these were just criminal
prisoners um and it was the same
building that had been used
during the soviet period and it was the
same building that had been used during
the czarist period so very often the
places in the buildings are the same and
then of course that also means that
institutionally
the behavior of the guards the customs
how people are
treated i mean there's a there's a kind
of constant institutional memory and
that's true of the present you know if
you if you read
mikhail horikowski who's a russian
businessman who was in prison for many
years if you read his memoirs you know
he talks about being treated by guards
in ways that sound very familiar to
anybody who's read a gulag you know
who's read the history of the gulag so
there are so although the numbers aren't
as great although they are building up
again slowly numbers of purely political
prisoners
um
art is large the prisons themselves the
systems by which they're run and
organized you know the language and
nature of the guards the the conditions
are
surprisingly there's there are
surprising similarities and echoes up
until the present so it's almost as if
you can you can change the politics but
you know you don't necessarily change
the jailers the same
you know the jailers still when someone
goes to work in a jail he's going to
work for an older person who used to
work in the jail and the if you haven't
had a major prison revolution or prison
reform i mean sorry um would you have
not had in russia you did not have it
after you know in the 1990s
then
you know why would they change you know
the system remains the system as it was
invented many years ago and it's been
altered i mean people aren't starved to
death anymore and they aren't work to
death anymore but
um but the system as it was in the 80s
and the system as it is now aren't
remarkably different which isn't
surprising given that the chain of
people the chain of um
you know the the training and the and
the experience of the guards is very
similar
classic quick question tim
we discussed foucault discipline and
punish last week in class and foucault
has this discussion of illegality where
he says it's important to create this
zone of illegality so that revolut
people who the class that might rebel
against the system is is thrown into
prison as criminals right they're
delegitimized as political prisoners so
one when they do seek to rebel you say
oh they're just common criminals um
is is that's obviously a theme in the
united states uh is that in to what
extent is that a really important theme
both in stalin's russia and in modern
russia i mean in stalin's russia there
were so many laws and there were so many
ways to break them that it was very hard
not to break any laws but even in modern
russia there's an excellent line there's
a book by um
christian freeland who's now a canadian
politician but who used to be a
journalist read a very good book about
russia was about the privatization era
of the 90s
and she had a line in it where she talks
about western advisers working in russia
constantly advising the russians they
say well you have all these
contradictory laws in which you know
people doing business and this you know
are always breaking a law because you
know the laws are unclear and she they
would keep pushing this you know this is
a big problem for you why don't you fix
this problem then suddenly it finally
eventually dawns on them it's on purpose
you know the laws are unclear for a
reason you know because everybody is a
criminal so anybody can be arrested at
any moment
for you know if the state doesn't want
them to be
you know if they don't like their
business or they're not paying enough
money to the mafia boss or whatever it
is that they're doing they've always
violated something
because the laws are badly written and
they seem to be written that way on
purpose and so yes absolutely
this this the unclear laws the badly
written roles the creation of
criminalizing you know in stalin's
soviet union there's a moment where they
criminalize um
um
you know the theft of grain becomes this
is in a moment of heavy starvation
becomes such a widely defined category
of behavior that you can be arrested for
picking up you know when someone's
carrying a bale of grain and you pick up
the leftovers and put them in your
pocket that can be a crime of theft from
the soviet state and you can go to
prison for five years
so the so both so all these systems have
that phenomenon that you know that many
ordinary activities are criminalized or
the laws are so badly written that
you're you're always bound to be
breaking one of them so yes
or destruct or the structures are such
that you have to break a law you have to
break a law in order to do business in
russia i mean you just can't do business
without breaking a law
yeah i mean one one interesting
difference like
between the us and russia i think people
can correct me
is that in russia
like
middle class people who are running
small businesses
are constantly afraid that they're going
to be arrested because they will be it's
very likely that they will be right and
then the us doesn't like them or wants
their business yeah yeah and in the u.s
at least if you're a white middle-class
businessman
you know this is not something you're
thinking about right the laws may be
contradictory but they're you're not
particularly worried about this and so
like you can have the same set of
friends
in you know in in in in cincinnati as
you do in param or whatever and they're
gonna have very different fears about
the police coming for them um
so yeah
no i i would say you know in
the in the us there are various
recourses you know you can
you can get lawyers and i mean there
there's a you know you're but but you're
right i mean the ordinary business
people just for doing their jobs are not
afraid of being arrested
yeah that okay and so like who is afraid
of that arbitrariness is obviously one
of the things we're thinking about i'm
gonna you've been very generous i'm
gonna give you two cl two two questions
together about about the us um knowing
that this is not what you really want to
talk about but also since you've kindly
volunteered to take part in the class on
mass incarceration in the us and the
soviet union and then one more question
about russia and then and then we'll
thank you again so there's a general
question which is um how have your
studies the gulag impacted your your
understanding of mass incarceration
in the u.s and then there's a more
specific um social and economic history
question which is
um if we link
labor control and race do you see common
threads between gulag camps and southern
us penitentiaries there were
specifically plantations
um
angolan louisiana
parchment farm mississippi and the texas
prison plantation system for example
um
so the first question
i don't know that my study of the gulag
has impacted
has it impacted my understanding of mass
incarceration in the u.s
i mean certainly study of the gulag and
more broadly study of the soviet union
has impacted my understanding of how
propaganda is used for example
um in in the us and europe and really
and everywhere else in the world um and
my you know
you know it's it's made me hyper
allergic and aware of certain kinds of
tactics and techniques that i you know
again i don't want to say that stalinism
is the same as anything we have in the
modern world again but there are there
are themes i mean it was while i was
writing my book about ukraine about the
ukrainian famine
um i realized sort of as one you know
tim and jason you probably had this
experience as well you know you get to
the end of the book and you suddenly
realize what it's about you know
um and this is what happened to me when
i wrote the ukraine book i got to the
end of the book and i suddenly realized
it's about dehumanization and hate
speech you know which wasn't how i
started out thinking about the book but
of course why was it possible to starve
the ukrainians it was because
they were you know vilified and you know
publicly vilified in this way and so
and so i i would say that my study of
the soviet union has
helped me to think about propaganda and
how it's used rather than
given many specific insights into the
american prison system i mean i would
i would put it that way
um
gosh is the u.s i mean the use of forced
labor um
you know there's actually a big argument
in the world of gulag studies as to
whether the gulag counts as a slave
system or not or whether it's something
different
and that's often a kind of semantic
argument about you know what should you
know how are these things similar and
how are they different
um
but i would say that the use of
forced labor and slavery does have some
common features
um
you know the again it has to be
accompanied by by a sense that the
people who are doing the forced labor
aren't of the same group as us
you know they have some
feature or you know it can be political
as it was in russia it could be ethnic
as it was in russia or it can be ethnic
as racial as it was in the united states
um they have to be
somehow qualified as not deserving of
having free will and the ability to
choose what kind of labor they do
and so you can you can say that that was
the same i mean so
the you know in the creation of special
categories of people who
um who don't deserve citizenship and who
don't deserve the protection of the rule
of law
i mean
the enormous difference is that there is
protection for the rule of law for some
people in the united states
which there isn't in russia at all
and so
hard to you know they aren't exactly
it's not exactly the same kind of
problem
um but but yeah i think the i think you
can make that comparison when you look
at
you know read carefully i mean this is
in my book um if you're reading part of
the book if you read the chapter on
guards i mean read the
the justifications that the guards make
to themselves you know why is it okay to
mistreat prisoners
um
that's somewhere i'm afraid i can't tell
you which page or which chapter number
it is anymore but um you know how how is
it the the guards tell them what do they
tell themselves about the prisoners
um and then you might have an
interesting basis for comparison to
slave owners you know what are they
telling themselves how are they
justifying it to themselves
that would be an interesting place to
look at what's the language being used
okay thank you thank you for for
stretching yourself in in our direction
i'm now going to give you a softball
soviet historiography question um
this is from from another student
uh if if the reason for the gulag was
fundamentally economic
was the stated reason for imprisonment
being the enemy of the people
simply a cover for the economic
imperative
you know actually no i you know maybe i
maybe i didn't explain myself that well
i mean the stated reason was economic
and when they talked among themselves
when when the stalin and the yeshov or
whoever the politburo were talking among
themselves they spoke about the gulag in
economic terms but that wasn't really
its only reason i mean it was also a
form of terror
um and so the
and so it had these dual functions but i
found the way they spoke about it
interesting for the reason that i just
answered
namely to justify it to themselves to
explain what they were doing remember
these are people who say in public as
you know we are internationalists we
believe in the brotherhood of all
peoples we're building the perfect
society we believe in
peace and brotherhood you know they had
to explain why this state which was
ostensibly
you know about creating good for mankind
why did it need to arrest millions of
people
and the reason they gave to themselves
was well
was was often economic when they when
they spoke among themselves but that
doesn't mean it was the only function of
the gulag the gulag maine you know i
mean how did it function in soviet
society and this you can get not just
from prisoners memoirs but from every
other memoirs and from literature as
well it functioned in soviet society as
a as a as a form of terror so people
were afraid of it you know if i do
something wrong i'll end up there
you know if i um
you know if i step out of line you know
my daughter will be arrested i mean you
know so so it really it functioned as a
thing in the back of people's heads that
that kept people in mind so it had it
actually had a number of different
functions um
and and the reasons for arrest you know
i mean again um
i mean there's a there's a famous anarch
matavo as a famous russian poet who used
to say you know when people would get
arrested or someone would be arrested
people would try to justify it oh well
so and so you know
we knew he would be arrested because he
said x or y you know she would say
don't you realize
you know everyone you're all you're all
arrested for nothing you know you could
invent any reason to arrest anybody i
mean anybody
and people you know the this is this is
another related subject um
the danger of anonymized
irresponsible bureaucracies is that
people could use them so you know you
were jealous of your neighbor's
apartment and you wanted to get you know
one of those rooms for yourself which is
that's how housing worked in the soviet
union you could denounce your neighbors
and say i heard them you know
saying something mean about stalin um
people would denounce other people to
you know because they were in love with
their wives and they wanted to you know
i mean so there was so the so the arrest
system was also used and manipulated by
um by ordinary people in order to um in
order to
you know to take advantage of it so
you know why you were arrested
i mean there could be a reason for it
you could belong to the wrong ethnic
group or be in the wrong place at the
wrong time or it could really be pretty
arbitrary
and random
okay
um we we haven't gotten through all the
questions we've gotten through most of
the themes of the questions you've been
very patient with us and we're grateful
for that as well as for
um the accessible art articulate um and
extremely helpful for us at the
beginning of our class lecture so and
thank you very much for for being with
us um thank you very much for your work
and thank you for helping us make a
start
well thanks thanks to both of you and
thanks to the students it sounds like a
fascinating class and i'm just sorry i
can't take it
you